♪ (orgue) ♪
- Mme Froment, bonjour.
- Bonjour M. Roy!
- Vous m'amenez à cathédrale
Marie-Reine-du-Monde.
Entrons d'abord.
Vous voulez nous faire découvrir
quelqu'un d'extraordinaire.
- Oui, c'est vrai. C'est le mot.
Oui, c'est quelqu'un
que j'admire beaucoup.
- Pourquoi?
SYLVIE FROMENT
- Parce que, d'abord, c'est
le prêtre de la paroisse où j'ai
été élevée. Puis quand mon père
a eu la maladie d'Alzheimer,
père Couturier était là pour
nous aider. Il nous a donné
un bénévole, nous avons vraiment
guidés dans ça. Ça a fait
toute la différence pour ma mère
et moi. Et aujourd'hui, je veux
lui dire merci. Et je l'admire,
père Couturier, parce qu'il a
une journée de congé par
semaine, qu'il consacre
à chausser les sans-abri.
- J'espère que vous êtes
en forme!
- Je pense que vous l'avez suivi
dans son parcours.
Il ramasse les vieux souliers
dont les gens ne veulent plus.
Il les répare. Il fait tout
avec ça.
- Bonjour. Ça va?
- Ça va bien, vous?
- Et je voulais souligner ça.
- Beaucoup d'espadrilles,
cette semaine.
- Vous trouvez que
c'est admirable.
- Oui, c'est le mot.
- Merci beaucoup, bonne semaine!
- Bien bravo, Mme Froment.
Merci beaucoup.
Jean-Pierre Couturier, bonjour.
- Bonjour! Ça me fait plaisir
de vous voir.
- On vous appelle le P'tit Père.
père JEAN-PIERRE COUTURIER
- Oui, ça m'est arrivé sur
un sac, un moment donné, où des
gens m'ont remis des chaussures
puis on a trouvé ça pas pire.
Alors, on a dit : OK, on va
appeler ça le P'tit Père.
- On m'a dit tellement
des belles choses sur vous.
D'abord, cette volonté d'aider
ceux qui en ont besoin,
les sans-abri, de les chausser.
- Oui.
- Ça vous est arrivé comment,
cette idée?
- C'est arrivé, j'étais vicaire
à l'époque ici, à la cathédrale.
Puis il y a des dames qui sont
venues me voir pour me dire que
notre Jean-Paul, qu'on voyait
tous les jours, commençait
à sentir pas très bon.
Je l'ai amené au sous-sol,
je l'ai déchaussé et là, j'ai vu
la gangrène qui était là.
Et c'est comme ça que
tout a commencé.
- On est donc à la cathédrale
Marie-Reine-du-Monde.
Vous êtes installé en bas.
- C'est ça. Après quelques
années ailleurs, j'ai finalement
demandé de me mettre ici, au
centre-ville, où tout se passe.
- Montrez-moi ça.
- Bien sûr. Avec plaisir!
♪ (orgue) ♪
Alors, laissez-moi ouvrir ici.
Ici, c'est aussi...
- Wow!
- Ça sert de dépôt. Vous savez
que de nombreuses églises
ferment et puis, c'est un peu
le dépôt...
- Est-ce que c'est des costumes
que les prêtres portent encore?
- Bien... non. Non, non.
- Non. Et là, on entre
dans votre antre.
- Alors, c'est ici l'atelier.
- Montrez-moi ça,
votre équipement.
- Bon, ça ici... Parce que j'ai
beaucoup de désordre et comme
il n'y a pas de pieds qui
attendent après les chaussures
que je dois réparer, j'y vais
au rythme que je veux.
- Votre matière première,
ce sont des souliers que
des gens laissent dans des
magasins quand ils s'achètent
de nouveaux souliers.
- Exactement.
- Et vous, souvent,
vous arrivez à en refaire
des souliers corrects.
- Absolument. Complètement
corrects. Et d'ailleurs,
je dis souvent : ça ne prend pas
grand-chose.
- Ah oui?
- Oui, oui. Il y a des questions
de mode, qui vont peut-être
justifier l'abandon d'une paire
de chaussures. Il y a aussi
le fait que... Vous savez,
vous connaissez peut-être
la blague qui veut que quelqu'un
change de voiture quand
le cendrier est plein.
Vous pouvez la transposer à
quand les lacets sont cassés.
Ils y en a qui vont changer
de chaussures...
- Bien, tant mieux,
dans une certaine mesure.
- Ah! Absolument. Absolument.
- Tant mieux, quand il y a
des gens comme vous pour
les récupérer.
- Pour les récupérer.
- C'est épouvantable qu'on les
jette. Mais c'est quand même
technique. C'est un métier que
vous avez appris ensuite par
vous-même. Essais et erreurs.
- C'est ça. Oui, oui.
Absolument.
- Ressemeler...
- Ressemeler, changer
les talons, coudre.
- Combien vous pouvez en faire,
comme ça? Et en distribuer?
- Je calculerais peut-être
12 boîtes qui peuvent contenir
jusqu'à une quinzaine ou une
vingtaine de paires par semaine.
- Wow!
- Ah oui, oui.
C'est beaucoup, hein.
- 200 par semaine?
- Ça donne ça, oui, à peu près.
- Mais vous êtes une usine
à vous tout seul!
- Oui, j'aurais besoin de
petits lutins, par exemple.
- Puis est-ce que vous croisez
des gens dans la rue qui portent
les souliers que vous avez
réparés, des fois?
Ça vous arrive, des fois?
- Bof...
(rire)
Probablement. Mais, je suis
jamais allé poser la question.
- Mais savoir que c'est utile,
ça vous amène quelque chose?
père JEAN-PIERRE COUTURIER
- Oui. Bien sûr. D'ailleurs,
au début, j'avais reçu
une question semblable :
"Pourquoi tu fais ça?"
Parce que je travaille dans
le domaine plutôt spirituel
et puis, là où on ne voit pas
les fruits. Parce que ça ne nous
appartient pas. Mais j'avais
besoin de quelque chose
de concret. Ça, c'est pour
la Maison du Père. Celle-là
n'est pas pleine encore, mais
j'ai bon espoir de la remplir.
- Le coût du matériel, père...
Couturier, qui paie pour ça?
- C'est moi.
- Vous payez pour
tous les talons...
- Oui, oui! Bien, j'ai eu
des dons aussi. Mais quand j'ai
une dépense à faire, bien...
la dépense à faire, il faut
la faire. Quand j'ai vraiment
des grands besoins, bien j'ai
une page Facebook, "Chez
le P'tit Père". Et... il y a
des gens là-dedans qui disent :
bon, j'ai de quoi
pour vous aider.
- Je suis anxieux.
- Ah oui?
- Tout ce qu'il y a à faire!
- Ah bien oui, mais écoutez,
si vous êtes libre un bon jeudi,
vous êtes le bienvenu.
(rires)
- Vraiment, merci de nous avoir
fait découvrir... On ne peut pas
se douter qu'il y a un père dans
le sous-sol de la cathédrale
Marie-Reine-du-Monde qui répare
des souliers et qui les donne
aux sans-abri, entre autres.
- Oui, entre autres, oui.
- On ne peut pas se douter
de ça.
- C'est ça. C'est des
originalités du Seigneur,
il faut croire!
(chant grégorien)